-Craig, you are up.
Come pull the mic.
Let's see what you get, buddy.
-[ Grumbles ]
-You got it. You'll be good.
Come on.
-That's fun.
-You got a Cardi B impression?
Let's see if it comes up.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Musical Genre Challenge.
Here we go.
-♪ Musical Genre Challenge ♪
-In this game,
you'll get a song title
and a completely different
musical genre.
Okay, then you're gonna have to
sing that song in that style.
Let's see what you get.
-[ Laughs ]
-Come on.
All right, here we go.
-Ohhhhhhh!
-You got this!
-You know "Candy Shop"?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah. Right.
-"Candy Shop" in a sexy
Motown version of that.
All right?
-He's got this.
-Craig, why don't you go over
there whenever you get ready?
-You gotta do it
Barry White-style.
-Adam, whenever you're ready,
bud.
-All right. All right.
-Let's take them to Detroit.
-♪ Yeah ♪
-Uh-oh.
-♪ Oh, so seductive ♪
♪ I'll take you
to the candy shop ♪
♪ I'll let you lick
the lollipop ♪
-Yeah!
-♪ Go ahead and, girl ♪
♪ Don't you stop ♪
-♪ Don't you stop ♪
-♪ Keep on going
till you hit the spot ♪
♪ You could have it your way ♪
♪ How do you want it? ♪
♪ Back that thing up,
or should I pull up on it? ♪
♪ Temperature rising,
go to the next level ♪
♪ Dance floor jam-packed,
hot as a teakettle ♪
♪ In the hotel
or back of the rental ♪
♪ On the beach,
it's whatever you into ♪
♪ I got the magic stick ♪
♪ I'm the love doctor ♪
♪ Have your friends teasin'
'bout how sprung I got you ♪
♪ The candy shop ♪
♪ I'll let you lick the lolly ♪
Clap your hands!
♪ Oh, girl, girl,
don't you stop ♪
♪ Keep on going
till you hit the spot ♪
♪ Whoaaaaa ♪
[ Sings indistinctly ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, a standing O!
They're standing. All right!
Oh, my gosh.
I never thought I'd hear that
in my whole entire life.